welcome everybody to Entertainment
Tonight in Arizona on this Championship
Monday coming to you from outside State
Farm Stadium where 24 hours earlier
Rihanna held her halftime baby shower
she did and sure did you could see the
aftermath right here you know everyone
is still buzzing over not only the
Chiefs Big Win go ahead glow glow down
I'm glowing and gloating but Rihanna's
sneaking her plus one into the stadium
[Music]
Riri and all red shocked the world
rubbing her belly just seven seconds
into her set a source tells E.T the
singer wanted to deliver a message of
empowerment and yeah she dropped a few
hints last week I really feels Like A
lot's happening all at once motherhood
are there any surprises I'm thinking
about bringing someone that someone
turned out to be baby number two with
ASAP Rocky who was cheering her on from
the sidelines the joke on Twitter now we
know why they call him ASAP we're told
they have always wanted to grow their
family and check this out E.T had eyes
on Riri and that baby bump backstage
just before hitting the field
foreign
but just how did she keep her pregnancy
Under Wraps at the presser Riri went
with a loose fitting jacket at the
Globes last month she wore a flowing
black gown and in December she covered
her tummy with her purse we're told when
Super Bowl officials reached out in
August they did not know she would be
pregnant
we've got more Super Bowl Secrets I
spoke exclusively to the halftime Show's
executive producer Jesse Collins who
explained how those soaring stages had a
practical purpose protecting players on
the field
[Music]
we were on a grass field there were
weight concerns and we were like you can
only do this much on the field and they
were like well we'll just put it all in
the air and you know apparently she's
scared of heights but she got it
together for this she got here last week
and practically every night she's been
flying she was 60 feet high and she said
she was actually more comfortable all
the way up at the top she loved it at
the top
[Music]
ReRe performed 14 songs in 13 minutes
and the setlist constantly changing she
was up to version 39 right I mean she
has a massive catalog not a lot of time
riri's maternity style the singer who
turns 35 next week kept it simple in a
cotton canvas red flight suit a source
tells E.T the costumes were being
tweaked up until the last minute
they designed those outfits it was kind
of an alien vibe that she said she was
going for and it was incredible she also
did this alone
I think it was just her wanting to make
the statement that she could carry this
thing and she did and I thought it was
just spectacular two hours before
Rihanna's reveal country star Chris
Stapleton took center stage with a
moving performance of the national
anthem that struck a chord with several
of the players and coaches on the field
foreign
it was such a moving rendition of The
Star-Spangled but what did it feel like
out there matter felt right it really
did you know the energy was good and the
crowds hopped up for the game so you
know that kind of gets you ready to go
[Music]
by all-female flight crew celebrating 50
years of women in Naval Aviation
[Music]
glad I'm done as you're up there you're
just hoping that you get through every
note and do it right I thought this year
was special because both you and Chris
went out there and played like it was an
honor to
be on the field with him because he's so
he's so good
and it was a it was a nice contrast for
for how I sing and how he sings and
stuff it was I thought it was well done
left out there now Shirley Ralph was
first out on the field and she waited
patiently as they announced the Walter
Payton Man of the Year and then she had
her moment
how was that performance how was that
moment that was a great moment we wanted
people to feel invigorated a new
inspiration for the song to know that we
have so many things we have still yet to
overcome but we can do it it can be done
as for Cheryl's show-stopping look she
did not have to look far for a stylist
when I found out that my mommy singing
the black national anthem I knew that it
was imperative for us to have a black
designer so I reached out to Charles
Harbison my mom said I have to have a
jumpsuit I have to be comfortable I have
to be Fearless but I also have to be me
and it came together so beautifully down
to the detail of the choir wearing the
pan-african colors in the background
that black that red that green That was
supposed to make a statement of course
there were plenty of stars in the
stadium Cheryl's Abbott Elementary
Creator Quinta Brunson Adele and her man
Rich Paul Sir Paul McCartney Bradley
Cooper Kevin Hart with a beer Tiffany
haddish Martha Stewart with first lady
Jill Biden and of course there's Jay-Z
the girl dad played photographer for 11
year old Blue Ivy and had to get her
approval
we saw them taking pictures when we were
down on the field
you and Jay-Z hanging out I saw I saw
talking about food and
exciting things coming up in the
pipeline
ET caught this father and son on the
field Chiefs fan Paul Rudd and his 17
year old Mini Me Jack you could even
hear the resemblance I can't believe it
I just want to thank Patrick Mahomes for
existing I cannot believe he's a real
person well we just made it on time
[Applause]
yes Rihanna fans assembled DJ Khaled
held up a lighter during the performance
her fanned out Cara Delevingne and Kerry
Washington called game day the Rihanna
concert did you dance on one of those oh
my goodness I don't think I could I have
like low-key a fear of heights
that's scary could you I've just been
sending Brianna so much love because I
know how nervous I was my first time
performing after having a baby and look
who was super polite making sure she
didn't run into our interview Christina
Aguilera is walking out that's a way
bigger game hi Christina hi Christine
of course the big game was also brother
versus brother Mom Donna Kelsey
celebrated with winner Travis
and made good on her E.T promise to not
forget about her other son now give him
a hug tell him I love him there is
nothing I can say that will make him
feel any better Donna also predicted
this would happen
he got it Travis will dance all the time
now a lot of fans are wondering why
Donna was seated away from her husband
Ed both were invited to watch from NFL
commissioner Roger Goodell's Luxury Box
he decided to sit with the family it's
almost stands oh Blue Collar Grunt and
who hosted 10 000 fans outside the
stadium let's go
that's how you start Super Bowl Sunday
yeah baby Guy Fieri who took the ET Mike
because I ate my way through the largest
tailgate ever presented by cash app with
tacos pretzels and Coney Island dogs I'm
a big hot dog guy he'll be right back
after these messages also partying it up
in Arizona MGK and Megan Fox but by
Saturday night there was big trouble
Megan posting this racy Revenge photo
and the cryptic Beyonce lyric you can
taste the dishonesty it's all over your
breath it's a constant process of like
suffering and passion by Sunday she
unfollowed him on Instagram scrubbed her
page of his picks then deactivated her
account but not before reacting to a
rumor that the rocker cheated with his
guitarist Sophie Lloyd Megan commented
simply maybe I got with Sophie he is not
allowed to have other hoes it's the
queen or no one so what's up well a
source tells E.T Megan was supposed to
be by his side at the Sports Illustrated
party Saturday but she backed out last
minute after the two had a big argument
they have a passionate relationship
filled with lots of intense emotions but
after this fight Megan was very upset so
was MGK he wasn't himself on stage we
were with him exclusively after the show
and as if things couldn't have gone
worse for The Rocker he was actually
electrocuted during his set
every time the sparklers or the smoke
would go off and I kept feeling my whole
body like Joe
everyone was like dude your hair kept
going crazy I looked at the pictures and
I was like oh yes this is when I got
electrocuted
over at the Fanatics party there was no
shortage of stars capitalized fun with a
f-u-n I'm holding some sparkly balls
running back turn the lights on when I
hit up Green Lantern Travis Scott
performed so did DJ Khaled and The
Chainsmokers Drew Taggart was there
without Selena Kevin Hart's plus one on
the carpet a shopping cart filled with
his own tequila you know he shared some
later with his wife aniko and fanatic
CEO Michael Rubin this Survivor party
you know you can't buy tickets it's
about bringing everyone together so they
have a great time inside Drake caught up
with Meek Mill Jade mingled with J
Balvin 81 year old Patriots owner Robert
Kraft got wild and out dancing with
Tiffany haddish then talked about newly
retired thirst trap Enthusiast Tom Brady
we at the Patriots were fortunate to
have the greatest of all time for 20
years so I pinched myself thinking about
it Shaq also hit the fnatic's carpet but
the night before it was Controlled Chaos
at his Funhouse bash presented by
NetSpend ET had the exclusive inside
here we are again at the Super Bowl's
craziest parties is the best Super Bowl
party ever in the invention of all
parties Snoop Dogg is going to perform
we're going to have a great night
overtime NBA champ also hit the DJ booth
at his annual over-the-top circus themed
party complete with this take the shot
basketball challenge
all right you want to shoot roads all
right I'll go first okay go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
one by default at the one party by Uber
new mom Paris Hilton took the stage for
the first time since she and husband
Carter Reem welcomed their son via
surrogate
Paris posed alongside friend Vanessa
Hudgins who made her first post
engagement appearance alongside fiance
Cole Tucker other couples hitting the
Arizona party scene Cher and Alexander
Edwards and Christina Aguilera who left
Drake's party with fiancee Matthew
rutler
Christina also took the stage during the
commissioner's party while Kane Brown
Dave Matthews and Flava Flav took part
in the Bud Light Music Fest
I might be jet lagged but I won't be
Kevin lagged I hear you
[Music]